Chris difficult day just talked us
through that incident that everyone's
talking about
yeah tough day out there I mean
obviously from a from a riding side of
things it was a great day for us another
day we can take off and I mean I was
tested by nairo quintana in the final
there but I felt quite within myself
able to respond and just happily sort of
keep my position on the general
classification unfortunately there was
there was an incident out on the road
which yeah it doesn't doesn't leave us
with a bit of good feeling a fan of
supposed fan at one point on one of the
drags quite early on in the stage
through a plots of urine at me while
shouting dope a like that
so it was it was clearly a French fan
and that it's not acceptable it's not
acceptable on any level obviously we're
all doing our level best out here to try
and try and race it as hard as we can to
try and change the image of the sport
that's that's obviously really important
to us and obviously this guy's got the
wrong end of the stick and he's taking
it out on us I mean we all want a clean
sport unfortunately I feel as if a lot
of the the reporting on the race has
been very irresponsible in terms of oh
can we trust this can we trust this
performance and that's that's obviously
led to a lot of people out on the roads
booing us and acting in this kind of
manner but I mean having said that it is
the minority it is absolute minority I'd
say it's it's it's a couple percent of
the thousands upon thousands of people
who are out there supporting us and and
cheering for all the riders so it's it's
a shame that one or two idiots can can
basically ruin it for Europe given that
incident do you worry about your
security now you're very exposed and we
are very exposed on the road
security is always a bit of a concern
especially when you've got that sort of
mob mentality in groups but we're in the
race organizers hands for that and we
hope that obviously they're going to do
everything they can to to make sure
we're not in a hostile environment out
on the road what's your message to
French cycling fans who don't believe
you are clean and are shouting abuse at
you and throwing urine at you you've had
a team mates spat on today another
teammate was punched earlier in the week
here what's your message to these people
my message to them would be try and make
up your own mind about things don't
listen to the likes of certain
commentators who are going to they're
from the old era these are ex cyclists
there's they're the ones saying listen
this performance looks dubious this this
doesn't look right to me and make up
your own mind you look at the race look
at how hard we work to get here we're
not we're not cheating and only only
time will tell
but it's it's a shame if we're going to
have to wait 10 15 years to really be
credited with the victories that we've
got here do you find it ironic that
you're the one cyclist who is
consistently open and honest you've had
journalists embedded with you on the
tour and you are repeatedly calling for
more testing that you're the one guy
that's asking for more and yet people
are abusing it certainly I mean for me
it's really important to be a spokesman
for clean cycling I mean it's a I feel
as if it's a it is something that falls
on my shoulders now to try and change
the image of the past and and obviously
the the Tour winners that came before me
who through the image of cycling out the
window
so I do feel a large responsibility and
I'm trying my level best to to try and
rectify that but it obviously doesn't
help when we've got these people on the
sidelines doing doing things like today
you've even said at the end of this tour
you will happily go to an independent
panel of doctors let them look at you I
just correct you there I wouldn't
necessarily say doctors I mean we're in
the middle of the race my focus is here
on the Tour de France but I am
open-minded to going and getting some
testing done not necessarily blood tests
or anything like that but oh it depends
what what people wants one one to see
but I'm thinking more physiological
testing something along those lines to
to maybe explain why my performances are
the way they are why I'm able to do what
I'm able to do I don't know if you'll
find any answers that's I'm certainly
open to it yeah and tell me how much
does it hurt them to have all the
questions and the abuse and the kind of
all the you know conspiracy theories why
is he able to do this it's it's
frustrating I won't lie it is
frustrating but at the same time it's
it's not gonna throw my focus off I'm
here to race I'm here to win
and that's it's not gonna change my
focus the same time it does it is
frustrating how that's that's all I can
say about it is it's a shame it has to
come with that same level of scrutiny
that that that we've got here at the
tour does that incident spory you want I
certainly I mean I think is it as a
group as a team I think it's it's
brought us all together in a way we all
feel as if like come on that's that's
let's dig in here let's let's do this I
mean come on everyone's we're up against
it here but you know what we've trained
pretty hard to be here excuse my French
we're not gonna let a few idiots ruin it
for us your one week away from Paris no
no British rider has ever won this race
twice how much of an incentive is that
to write history that's that's not
really what I'm about to try and write
history and but I mean obviously I want
to be the best sportsman I can be I want
to I want to make my family proud I want
to make my friends proud I want to make
all the people who've got me here my
mentors my coaches I want to make them
proud I've got I've put a little kid on
the way I'd love to be able to say to
him one day look what your dad did when
when you were in your mom's tummy those
those are my motivations fatherhood when
the time comes if your little boy says
to your daddy I'd love to be a
professional cyclist given you know how
hard it is it's excruciating at times
and yet immensely pleasurable yeah would
you be happy for your son to become a
cyclist one day I definitely wouldn't
discourage him from it it's it's a
beautiful sport I mean I I love the
sport through and through otherwise I
certainly wouldn't be doing what I'm
doing now yeah certainly I mean I'd be
pretty proud to have have a little one
on a bike in a few years time tell me
about the guys in Team Sky they killed
themselves most days you know for you
yeah and the spirits the camaraderie the
unity what's it like inside that truck
with especially this year we really do
have a tight-knit group of guys who it
seems as if everyone's got good days and
bad days
some guys struggling on on certain
stages and we're all just for changing
roles within the team and just getting
through each day one day at a time
trying to just get oh that they're just
trying to carry me to the finish
obviously and invest in the best best
way possible and it's it's been
fantastic the guys have done such a good
job like the job up until now I mean if
we look at all the hurdles we've we've
had in that first week we had torrential
thunderstorms with cross
and the cobbled stages but all the way
through the guys have been there and
right up into through the Pyrenees I've
always had either Garant on us or Richie
bought with me I can't I can't thank the
guys enough for the work they've done
for me here people back home are saying
that Chris Froome 2015 is the mentally
stronger that that they've seen you
where where does that come from you know
we see you on the television we see you
in pain and yes you dig it out time and
again when you're attacked people are
coming at you where do you get your
mental strength from um I mean I
definitely feel as if from a lot more
prepared this time around for it and
then I was two years ago I felt like two
years ago it was still very new to me it
was sort of a big scary experience
whereas this time round I feel as if
okay I know what I'm up against here
right I've done this before there's no
reason why I can't do it again but I
mean at the end of the day this is this
is by creating this is sport I mean we
should be enjoying it and we are it's
mature to be in this position
I asked Sir Dave Brailsford earlier on a
couple of questions about some of the
kind of internet conspiracy theories out
there about Team Sky yeah he said they
are hilarious so I'm gonna ask you to
your face now people say that you have
some sort of hidden motor device inside
your bicycle that drives you on yeah
I've heard it all on this racing motors
to all of its I mean in a way it's got
to be the greatest compliment that
people think I've got a motor in my bike
but I mean I don't really take it like
that obviously it's it's it does get
irritating and it's it's silly I mean
the authorities are checking our bikes
for motors just for the record
but yeah I mean it's it is crazy some of
the stuff you read out there but I guess
sort of thought always be conspiracy
theorists out there people say you drink
an energy drink that cost 2,000 pounds a
liter is this yeah that's that's another
one actually has a quote that made us
laugh we had to actually get on to get
onto internet and google the name of the
drink to see exactly what it was but now
there's certainly no 2000 euro Alita
drinks happening on TV sky all motors or
anything like that the next week looking
ahead it it's a week that defines your
year and your in your career yeah and
how do you switch off in the evenings
you know knowing how big every day is
that's coming do you do you relax do you
read do you ring Michelle oh yeah I was
try and try and give the wife a call
give Michelle a call
that's always nice just to hear what's
happening at home put some music on this
to be honest is not too much time in the
evenings once we finish for dinner you
pretty much want to hit the hit the sack
and try and get some rest before before
you're up early the next day for for
another big stage so there's not a lot
of downtime so what little downtime we
have we try and try and keep in touch
with family to all the legions of fans
back home who are following your
progress and who loved what you were
doing for the sport and they believed in
you and they love that you were riding
clean and they support you all the way
what's your message to them I mean the
support we've had from back home is just
unreal just the thousands upon thousands
of messages of Union Jack's out on the
roads of people who have actually made
it their mission to come out here and
follow us day by day holding whatever
banner or support support message it's
it's unreal it's unreal and I just want
to thank those people from the bottom of
my heart thank you so much for the sport
and it it really means a lot to us and
it gets us through the stages just
looking ahead to the next few days and
heading into Paris hopefully with you in
a yellow jersey yeah what does it feel
like you've done it once before what to
feel like when protocol dictates that
you don't get attacked on the on the
right into Paris and Sean's alizée and
you know you're there I almost feel a
little bit too superstitious to be
talking about that just yet I mean it
was still good a week to go and I mean I
am in a fantastic position with over
three minutes advantage to to second
place and of course every day I'm
thinking about what its gonna be like to
to write down that Sean's at lycée and
be in that kind of position but I'm not
gonna let myself get too carried away
just yet I've got to get there first I
met a man two years ago in Kenya who was
your old mentor David Kinjo truly a
remarkable man how much of an influence
was he on you two how he learned how you
rolled to begin with and he gave you
belief definitely definitely in kyndra
kyndra was a huge inspiration to me when
when I was a teenager back in Kenya and
it was just amazing to me that he was a
professional at the time and he just
said to me come on get your bike come on
let's let's go training and to me it
just felt felt amazing that you could
you could connect with people like that
and experience the outdoors and in such
a way it was it was just for me it was
freedom as a teenager on a bike and
kynges inspired a lot of youngsters it's
been sad that that more haven't been
able to to move away from from Kenya on
to the professional scene but he's doing
a great job back in Kenya now motivating
youngsters and working working with with
an Academy they're so
no they definitely definitely keep up
the good work and you there's one final
question the next few days
you must really hope you don't get the
level of aggression and hostility and
abuse that you've had today certainly
certainly I mean I'd like to think
that's that's hopefully behind us now
and having drawn attention to it these
last few days with with the incidents
that have happened hopefully it's going
to die down a bit now but who knows I
mean it's to the front and anything
could happen out here so your message to
everyone that doubts you Chris Froome
riding clean winning clean and like I
said before time time will tell but only
only I know that and unfortunately other
people are going to have to wait a bit
longer to see that for themselves